So I want to spend just a few minutes talking
about the November 2020 election, but the
context is really going to be coronavirus
because there's a very interesting new study
which found that if you break down Donald
Trump's approval rating in counties where
Corona virus is raging versus in counties
where it is not, this is a county level analysis.
Counties that are seeing the highest rates
of corona virus explosion have seen a dramatic
drop in Donald Trump's approval rating.
And the reason this is important is that last
week I did a segment pointing out that, you
know, when we think about the Biden versus
Trump debates, assuming that they happen,
Biden pointing out that Trump is crass and
makes fun of people and is a bully and grab
them by the You-Know-What and the racism and
xenophobia and all that stuff.
It hasn't worked so far.
And I can't imagine that it's going to all
of a sudden start working for Joe Biden if
that's the approach he decides to take.
My instinct was we've seen Trump's approval
come down because of three major issues over
the last four months.
Number one, the handling of Corona virus.
Number two, the handling of the economy in
the context of the failed handling of corona
virus.
And number three, the insane reaction to protests
against police brutality, which included authoritarian
anti speech tendencies and threats to send
in troops with even more force to protests
that are against police brutality to begin
with.
That's where the focus should be and particularly
the failure of leadership.
Language aside, if Trump uses coarse language
but he crushes the virus and does the right
thing when it comes to protests and the economy.
OK, who's going to care about the coarse language?
And that's basically my idea.
And indeed, Donald Trump has seen the fastest
declines in his approval rating in the 500
counties where there have been more than 28
corona virus deaths per 100000 residents.
That's sort of like the dividing line.
Pew Research Polling shows that 17 percent
of the country which approved of Trump in
March now disapprove.
So it's starting with just the slice that
approved in March.
17 percent of that now disapproves.
And this is a in those counties and this is
a massive drop and we're not even near the
end of the pandemic.
And.
It's always tragic when it takes friends or
family members getting sick or dying to wake
up and have a realization, it's like the anti-gay
Republican politician who changes their tune.
Typically his tune, but their tune when someone
they know comes out as gay.
Great.
They came to the right conclusion.
But why did it take that you couldn't empathize?
Well, it seems like that's at least part of
what's going on here.
And there's a very reasonable debate over
how much is Trump's fault in terms of the
cases and deaths.
Obviously, people were going to die.
You can't say of one hundred and thirty two
thousand deaths.
One hundred and thirty two thousand.
Are Trump's fault.
But you can put numbers on what was the cost
of not developing a testing program starting
January 20th, the way South Korea did when
we both got our first cases on the same day.
You can make estimates about what would a
mask recommendation have done early on?
What would stay at home have done early on?
Hospitals could have maybe not been underwhelm
like, you know, overwhelmed.
You can put numbers to this.
And so, you know, people who want to argue
Trump doesn't have one hundred and thirty
two thousand deaths on his hands, of course
he doesn't.
I don't know anyone who's actually making
that case.
What we know is that there are specific policies
and specific actions, including the rollout
of the testing program and many other things
that could have been done differently, which
would have saved lives.
And it's not could have been done differently.
But nobody did that.
Many countries did.
South Korea is an example.
There are many others.
Remember that on February 26, Donald Trump
said we have 15 cases and 15 is soon going
to zero.
That was February 26.
We now have almost three million cases and
one hundred and thirty two thousand deaths
and cases are exploding in a huge swath of
this country.
So that's the context.
And it is, again, evidence that the pandemic
and Trump's reaction are dramatically hurting
his polling.
Now, to zoom out a little bit bigger picture,
we continue to get national polling where
Trump is down by double digits.
We also are seeing real clear politics polling
averages in Wisconsin, Michigan, Pennsylvania
and Florida, where Biden is ahead by five
or more points.
That's insane.
Arizona, which has been a Republican stronghold
for a long time.
Biden ahead by an average of three and a half
and a half.
The really crazy thing to think about is that
if Donald Trump had just taken medical advice
and gone the route of other countries that
chose chose science over ignorance and action
over politics.
If he had controlled the corona virus and
supported a shutdown, supported of an actual
real testing program starting in January,
tracing initiatives, et cetera, et cetera,
he would have an all but guaranteed reelection
in November.
I am increasingly confident that that is that
that that is how important this is ultimately
going to be.
And it's also crazy to think that if Trump
and Pence had just caught the flu or a bad
intestinal bug on January 20th and been MEAA
for a month and just let medical doctors make
decisions, we would also be far better off.
In other words, their presence was not only
not positive, it was acutely negative in dealing
with coronavirus.
The data is in the polls.
And so what do we all have to do now?
Exactly.
We don't believe any one of the polls, we
imagine that our individual votes could be
the difference makers in our states and every
single one of us gets an absentee ballot or
goes in votes or does whatever it is that
we can do to ensure that Donald Trump is removed
in November.
The polling looks good.
Ignore it.
Pretend the polling looks terrible.
Pretend every state is 50/50.
And that you could be the difference maker.